وضع معيشي صعب وتحديات اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
تبدو حلولها صعبه التحقيق هذا الحال دفع
الياس للتسلل الى نفوس بعض اللبنانيين
خلال الاشهر ثلاثه الاولى من العام الحالي
وثقت احصاءات رسميه ست وثلاثين حاله
انتحار فيما سجلت احصاءات اخرى 50 حاله
انتحارا خلال اربعه اشهر
من قدام عيوني
قررت انهي حياتي خلاص انا برتاح يعني انه
انا برتاح ورب العالمين يمكن تولى امر
المعالجه النفسيه في جمعيه امبريس تقول
انه في العام الماضي سجلت
138 حاله انتحار فيما سجل منذ بدايه هذا
العام 38 حاله
الى ان هذه الارقام قد لا تكون دقيقه لان
الكثير من حالات الانتحار لا يعلن عنه
الانتحار لمساله كتير معقده ما الا رابط
واحد هي نتيجه تراكمات عديده بتصير اكيد
المساله الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه اللي صارت
بلبنان اثرت على الاشخاص اللي عندهم مرض
نفسي ولكن ما في يقول انه هي الرابط
الوحيد يشهد لبنان منذ عام 2019 ازمه
اقتصاديه وماليه صنفها البنك الدولي بين
الازمات الثلاث الاسوا في العالم منذ
منتصف القرن التاسع عشر
وتؤثر هذه الازمه بشده على الاوضاع
الاجتماعيه للبنانيين وتعرقل حصولهم على
الخدمات الاساسيه كما تتسبب بتدهور
الاوضاع الانسانيه نور الحصن العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات